president Trump's former chief
strategist vows to go after vulnerable
Republican senators in next year's
midterm elections just weeks after
leaving the White House Steve Bannon is
targeting Republicans he views as
standing in the way of the president's
agenda he promises to use his influence
to support more populist challengers
Nancy Cordes is on Capitol Hill with
bannon's plan and GOP reaction to that
plan Nancy good morning good morning yes
some Republicans worried that bannon's
crusade as he outlined in that 60
minutes interview with Charlie Rose is
going to cost them their narrow Senate
majority they believe that the
candidates he favors would not fare well
against Democrats in swing states but
Bannon insists he isn't hurting the
party
he's remaking it people that are not
supporting the President's agenda that
are coming up for election in 18 they
ought to understand they're gonna get
primary in his interview with 60 minutes
Bannon issued this warning to Republican
lawmakers who crossed the president
there's not going to be an opportunity
to be in nevertrump okay you're either
going to get with the program and with
the president's program and have his
back are you gonna be held accountable
and maybe have a primary challenger
absent 100% Bannon has already vowed to
take down Arizona Senator Jeff Flake
Alabama Senator Luther Strange and
Nevada senator Dean Heller he's backing
more populist or conservative
challengers like Nevada Attorney Danny
Tarkanian Tarkanian has run
unsuccessfully for office in Nevada five
times and met with Bannon last week he
told me that he and Breitbart is going
to be a hundred percent in my race and
supportive of me and that we can count
on him now that he's not in the White
House Bannon is free to use his ties to
wealthy donors and his widely read
website to fire warning shots at
Republicans like Tennessee senator bob
Corker who recently said the president
lacks stability and competence corker is
debating whether to run again in 2018
some top Republicans like John McCain
view bannon's threats as a nuisance do
you think the party would be stronger if
several incumbents were unseated that's
what he believes
I'm supposed to comment on what Steve
Manon believes good night but other
Republicans don't dismiss bannon's plans
quite that easily as one top Republican
aide put it to me Nora
every dollar that Bannon spends on one
of these primaries is a dollar that
Republicans need to spend protecting
their incumbents instead of going after
Democrats pants thank you John McCain
never one to mince words thank you oh I
like that tactic just say good night
conversation over